we are about to kick off our eighth
Gladiator the forge competition with our
five-time winner Jesse and our
competitor Matt trying to stop that
Reign of Terror
what are you picking today I want to
pick the forge welding technique
interesting all right what are you
thinking I'm thinking
ball bearing canister with a peeled
canister
oh bold very risky move all right now
Matt gets second choice
you have a choice of a few weapons here
on the wall of gladiator blades what are
you thinking I've done official canister
Damascus I've done chain canister
Damascus I've never had anything to do
with ball bearings honestly I don't even
know what type of metal that it is
without doing research so I look at the
wall but I think it will keep it within
my wheelhouse Gladius
the Roman Gladius is one of the most
well-known weapons of the Roman Empire
tracing its origin back to the 2nd
Century BC this weapon features a
lightweight double-edged blade designed
for easier more deadly strikes than
other heavier Blades of the era which
made it the sword of choice for both
Roman soldiers and gladiators
this iconic weapon was featured on the
very first season of forged and fire
where both Smiths went above and beyond
with their Damascus blades but struggled
to perfect the intricate handle
Construction
your time starts now the last thing that
I want is my steel not welding together
so I get all that powdered steel settled
in between all the ball bearings almost
like making a ball bearing lasagna pack
it down the best that I can and weld the
top
I'm ready to stop Jesse's winning streak
and I'm ready to go on to the next and
then the next plenty of time plenty of
time
canister comes up like what I think is
ready to go and we start squaring It Off
I get to the point where it looks as if
I've got one solid piece of Steel
I'm ready to take the canister off
as I am peeling off the can I look down
at the steel and there's little ball
bearings on my inside
it kind of freaks me out it doesn't look
right uh oh guys Matt just put his
Billet down on the ground back by his
fights I just make a quick decision
starting over over and over we got a
restart my question is is why did he
reach start they only open to 10 minutes
to see what's going on in there
the second can gets up to heat
oh
it comes off easy looks to be one solid
piece of Steel I've got my second Billet
drawn out and as I'm hammering
a ball bearing actually falls off
oh no ah I cannot believe I've got to do
it a third time oh wow are you kidding
me guys too aggressive on that first
pass I think you're right I've got to
hurry Emma I've completely lost track of
the clock
just me in that third game and I am
going to win
the last piece pops off oh my God it's
time to work a shape that just to give
myself a blade profile that I can work
with Matt is real
for just turn off
it's gonna go to the forge I mean this
idea that you can't grind after you
quench I don't know what is where you
want to shout out are you sure
so I know the forge is going to cut off
at the two and a half hour mark But
quenching it without a thermal cycle
I've got the chance of some catastrophic
failures so I'm going to use the oxy
acetylene to do my heat treat this is
literally risking everything
okay what the hell white space you have
two hours and 30 minutes left
so I know the forge is cut off so last
minute decision I said let's do an edge
quench
with the oxy acetylene torch the only
thing I have to work with is a very
small flame that's only going to get
concentrated areas on that steel hot
enough for a heat tree
how long will it take him to get this up
to temperature for a proper quench way
too long
I've lost 15 minutes and my steel is not
up to temperature Matt's torch it's just
not as hot as it can be it will take way
too long to eat this plate she has not
got the gas mixture on that right that
should be our screaming hot blue flame
about a quarter inch off the end of that
Rosebud maybe underneath I'll just soot
everything that's there maybe the blade
is a little bit redder than what I think
so I quench it's not even smoke coming
out of there I don't know what I'm gonna
do but I'm gonna push I've got to move
on the blade is just gonna have to do
I've got to get a handle on it
I'm mentally exhausted physically
exhausted but I get my handle on it
doesn't even have a way to fix the
handle we're looking at an incomplete
blade not stopping until somebody tells
me to stop
I think Dan Nielsen's videos that I'm
supposed to let this white out dry
somewhat I decide to risk it and just go
back and pack it while the white out is
still pretty liquid
oh it looks like my fours just got
possessed that's all material burning
out of the inside of the can that
creates a void
the first two welding Heats go very very
well
but I don't have extra vision
the only way that I can tell what's
inside this can is to start peeling it
open I did have a lot of energy going in
this competition but it's all being
sapped away by the most draining process
I've experienced yet
I wish they chose a different forging
technique this sucks finally holy
after 45 minutes of chiseling away the
last side of the can comes off I am
ridiculously happy but I just barely got
started and I need to make a full-blown
sword there's not a single inch on this
Billet where there's no cracks
I get most of these cracks grounded in
the building I'm just super lucky now
it's time to take it to old big blue and
completely draw it out and get ready for
beveling after I've done forging on my
blade I need to get some good
normalizing Cycles I want there to be as
small a chance as possible a little bit
cracking in the quench
Jesse quenched nice color all throughout
the quench goes perfectly and I don't
see any cracks on the blade
it's time to hog off the most material I
ever have and get this blade to its
final shape
[Music]
Jesse's handle looks great really nice
globe on the back of it and now it's
time to put an edge on this thing I need
to make sure that it cuts and slices
through anything that the judge can
throw at it five four three two one tell
me turn off your machines put down your
tools this battle is over
mediators to the forge welcome to the
kill test
let's see if you're glad to have a
Gladius
just here first you ready for this I'm
ready
all right Jesse let's talk about your
Gladius looks like six times the charm
because this is the best handle you've
presented us everything is nice and
tight it is smooth and it's a void to
where I can get a really good grip on
this fits nicely in my hand
your tip is pointy enough to puncture
nicely and your Edge is sharp enough to
cut the big carcass down overall sir
you're Gladius
he'll kill thank you
Matt your turn sir you ready ready let's
do this
my blade has so many issues my biggest
concern is because of the heat treat on
my blade it's going to hit a bone that's
just going to shatter
I like my questions about this handle I
don't really see a mechanical connection
I think just held by Glue what do you
guys think my biggest question is is
that thing hard it was quenched at such
a low temperature it can't be the only
way to find out
this Blade's just not hardened
all right Matt unfortunately after doing
a file check we've determined that your
blade is not hard now we consider that a
parameter failure and cannot continue
testing your blade fairly against your
competitors I want to say thank you so
much for coming out fighting so hard
never giving up in this competition but
unfortunately I'm gonna have to ask you
to please step off the fourth floor
I understand thank you Matt thank you
thank you Matt good fight well Jesse man
I know this is probably not the way that
you wanted to win a competition but you
have taken down six competitors you have
40 000 in your pocket and six gliding
the forged titles man congratulations
[Applause]
I didn't expect it wouldn't even have of
this much everything is still a blur
everything's still a surprise
again congratulations we gotta ask you
do you want to go back into the forge
for another eight hour round and battle
it out for another title
of course
all right well congratulations man we
will see you for another one on the
fourth floor well done thank you I'm
Jesse who I'm the sixth time Gladiator
of the forge and I'm not scared about
next competition